barack obama got in this now barack of
course was joe biden's boss for eight
years obviously did not do a very good
job at anything uh because if he did
then joe biden wouldn't have to be
president right now and donald trump
would have never been president but a
lot of people were pissed after eight
years of obama but obama did i mean i'm
going to show you this twitter thread
the worst
sort of making everything political and
really read this does this strike you as
a good man who is trying to heal what's
going on in this country heal the thing
that we're all feeling
or is this someone who purely wants
political power it's disgusting actually
uh here's obama as we grieve the
children of valdez today we should take
time to recognize that two years have
passed since the murder of george floyd
under the knee of a police officer his
killing stays with us all to this day
especially those who loved him
in the aftermath of his murder a new
generation of activists rose up to
channel their anguish into organized
action launching a movement to raise
awareness of systemic racism and the
need for criminal justice and police
reform
then he continued inspired by these
young leaders mbk alliance launched a
reimagining policing pledge for mayors
and cities ready to take action if
you're wondering how you can get how you
can help to make things a little better
today here are some ways to get involved
i mean this is absolutely incredible
what he did there first off this
shooting has absolutely nothing
nothing nothing nothing to do with
george floyd but obama come by he's a
politician more than anything else we
thought he was hope and change and he
turned out to be something very very
different he is nothing other than a
paper bag politician who is taking the
murder of 19 dead kids to somehow try to
combine it into something that has to do
with george floyd and of course he says
systemic racism and systemic racism is a
phrase much like common sense gun laws
which just sort of means nothing no one
denies that there is racism but there
are no racist laws in the united states
also he forgets you know he talks about
the two years of protests and things
that we had yeah that's right there were
uh an awful lot of you guys remember
them when we lived in la the destruction
that was everywhere all the destroyed
stores all the signs that were put up on
all the stores that said i'm for blm and
peace and tolerance and they put those
signs up so that their stores wouldn't
be destroyed by the peaceful tolerant
people and they still burned them down
anyway and broke all their windows and
the rest of it um so obama
man
the greatest shyster of all time perhaps
hope and change was this the hope and
change you now combine
the murder these kids are not even
buried yet you freak
and you dare combine this basically with
blm and antifa who destroyed who gave us
two years of mass violence
two years of mass violence like vile
absolutely vile then there was another
one
this one man i i you know what by by
later by tomorrow we're getting back to
some funny stuff okay that's my
commitment to you guys
but we have to do this when we have to
do it we have to do it to make some
sense of the world uh here's a tweet by
a guy by the name of rick lewis and he
found
one of the fathers of who was mourning
his child
okay this guy the picture that you're
seeing there i don't even care about who
this rick lewis person is doesn't matter
uh but the person you're seeing there is
a father who just lost one of his
children
this this blue check oh no no sorry he's
not blue check he's got a blue heart but
this person on twitter found this guy's
who just lost his kid found some of his
previous social media posts and found
out that he was for the second amendment
and he was for kyle rittenhouse and he
went after him he said the father of one
of the victims from the texas shooting
was pro-gun and literally championing
kyle rittenhouse on facebook and this is
and then of course you know it's like
man the guy's child just died that tweet
went very viral so i'm not even making
it about this random person on twitter
it's because they find anything to make
it political it's theater
it is theater instead of offering a
little bit of sympathy for someone whose
child just died i cannot imagine
anything worse in the human experience
it's oh he's for guns
and what that is is a difference of
political opinion
the father believes that you should be
able to defend yourself i suspect he
still does right now and i would suspect
i don't want to talk about it but i
would suspect that he probably feels if
the school had done a better job
defending itself that this would have
never happened but now is not the time
to discuss that